hello and welcome to a very special
episode of trigonometry where I'll be
talking to Constantin all about Tucker
Carlson's interview with Vladimir Putin
if you want to ask Constantin any
questions send us through a Super Chat
and we'll be answering them in the
second half of the
episode welcome mate good to good to be
here thanks for having me yeah just
before we get into the main body of the
interview the one thing that I found
very interesting was actually the
response on social media to the whole
interviews it was it was quite
interesting wasn't it social media and
the media and I I I have to say I think
if whoever you listening to or reading
or follow on in Twitter Instagram
whatever anyone who had an opinion on
this before they saw the interview or
before the interview was out you should
stop listening to cuz these are people
who are prepared to have an opinion on
things they haven't seen but we laugh
but it's it's actually quite a
legitimate point because we live in this
world where there's like this
really crazy perverse incentive
structure for people to comment on
things before they've even been released
and I just think it's so discrediting if
you do that so obviously everyone has
their own preconception about Putin the
war or whatever but an Tucker MH and I
certainly do on all those things I've
been on his show a couple of times I
very much disagree with the positions
he's taken on Russia and Ukraine Etc but
you have to listen to the thing before
you comment on the thing that's kind of
basic
isn't it it was about five years ago
mate not anymore really sadly well
that's kind of it so uh I guess what
people the big the big debate was is it
good journalism or not and that's the
one thing you really cannot assess until
you watch the interview because you can
dislike Tucker and think he's not a
great journalist but he might have done
a great piece of Journalism or you can
really like Tucker and then you know he
might not have done a great you have to
actually see the thing so the question
is have having watched it number one was
it a good piece of Journalism and I
actually don't know the answer to that
because it really depends on what you
mean right we watched it it's a 2hour
and 20 minute interview the first two
hours plus he ask a question and lets
Putin answer and that's all that really
happens he tries to interject once or
twice Putin kind of steam rolls over it
I'm sure we'll talk about it yeah um and
then at the end when he asked about the
American journalist who Putin things as
a spy uh then there's a little bit of
back and forth and actually they get
into a bit of a a more more like answer
push back type of situation which
doesn't really go very far uh so is that
good journalism is it good journalism to
let Putin talk for two hours without
interruption I actually kind of think it
is because one of the things as you know
I've been doing is translating Putin
speeches not because I agree with Putin
but I think it's really important for
people in the west to hear his point of
view not because it's necessarily a
legitimate point of view but I actually
do agree with Tucker that most of it not
all of it but most of it Putin believes
sincerely so whether he's right or wrong
or whether what he's saying is true or
not you do need to know what your
adversaries are thinking right so from
my perspective I have no problem with
the way Tucker conducted the interview
would I have liked to see him challenge
more yes would I have liked to see him
be better prepared yes would I have
liked the interview to be 5 hours
instead of two so that could happen yes
are any of those things possible why I
don't know right so but certainly the
idea that Putin went up there to like
big him up didn't come across that way
to me however obviously not everybody
sat there and watched the full 2hour and
20 minute interview some people just
liked you know hearing Putin look
presidential and you know look more less
demented than Joe Biden and whatever
that seemed to be like the r toid
talking point you know look how great he
looks which is a very superficial way to
look at it I think um and the leftwing
talking point was you know put tuck is
just giving him a platform was if Putin
needed a platform you know so it was
kind of two very stupid sides arguing
and making very stupid points in my
opinion one thing I think that can't be
disputed actually and again there's a
human element where I look at Tucker and
it's very easy to go oh he should have
done he should have done that he should
have done this he should have done that
when the guy is in the Kremlin and
opposite one of the most powerful men in
the world
in his country in his country literally
in his Capital where people do regularly
fall out of Windows come down with
strange diseases exactly
exactly but having said all that
Vladimir Putin was in control right the
way through and he did something very
interesting where he was saying well is
this going to be a chat or is this going
to be something more serious which I
thought was a very interesting playy
what did you think about that well I
think what he was doing is he was
essentially saying to Tucker like let me
talk and let me lay out my serious
points this isn't a talk show where you
get to interject every 3 seconds and
whatever uh and you're completely right
he was in control by the way a lot of
people who may be watching him for the
first time or reading a speech of his
for the first time are like oh my God I
can't believe you talk about the history
of Russia for 40 minutes which I'm sure
we'll get to actually every speech he
does now is like a three-hour speech and
the first hour is about the history of
Russia he's quite use at this point
having been in power for 2 years now you
know to being listened to to holding
Court uh and this is you know people
will say this is my anti-putin bias but
it's just the fact when you've been in
power for 25 years your power is
Undisputed and unchallenged you start to
feel like you can you know take your
time to explain things that people need
to hear and um and we saw this with the
Fidel Castro you know giving 12-hour
speeches this is quite normal for people
who have been in power for a long time
it just is and by the way even in a
democratic country I mean you know
Thatcher used to go on quite a bit
people would kind of say that do you
know what I mean like people who who are
in those positions for a very long time
are used to going on at length about
their opinions and so that's kind of how
you what you saw playing out yeah indeed
and Tucker was you could see he was
quite surprised actually and he said in
his you know opening address to Camry he
thought was filibustering on Putin's
behalf but it wasn't so let's get into
the history of Russia what did you
actually think about his description of
the history of Russia was it accurate
yeah it was so broadly speaking what
he's saying about the history of Russia
is entirely correct and what I found
very interesting is how many people were
saying that oh he was just saying all
this irrelevant stuff and it's only
irrelevant if you don't understand the
point he's actually trying to make which
is very very obvious he spends half an
hour basically making the case for the
fact that Ukraine is not a legitimate
country it has no right to exist and
most of it is Russian land populated by
Russian people and it belongs to Russia
now what's interesting is Tucker
actually does challenge him and says
well you know why why have you not said
that for the first 22 years of your
being in power and Putin never answers
interestingly enough um which is telling
and the point Chuck is making to him is
you never Justified your invasion of
Ukraine in
2022 in these terms and yet as Putin has
done in every big speech he has done he
keeps talking about this point that
these are our lands populated by Russian
people Russian speakers without ever
saying the thing that he actually is
saying which is basically it's my land
I'm entitled to it yeah and what's
interesting as well is that he even
talks about the word Ukraine and says
like it has no meaning in the sense of
of a country which I found very
interesting look the fact is
historically the points he's making not
incorrect in the Ukraine didn't really
exist as a country prior to being formed
during the Soviet period even during the
Soviet period it was given lands both
from the Russian part and from what was
Hungary and Romania and it was kind of
made into this artificial country you
might say then again there's quite a lot
of artificial countries in the world
This Is Not Unusual and in any case even
that all being true that is not the
justification for The Invasion that he
ever gave if he said you know this is
Russian territory we're taking back we
could then have a debate about whether
that's a legitimate kazas Bell or not
legitimate cause for war or not but he's
kind of saying one thing while claiming
a different thing as the cause for this
for this war which I'm sure we get to no
absolutely and before we move on he he
said like Lenin inexplicably gave these
territories away right sorry to deject
but I'm so insens about this point and I
have been for the last two years because
the a lot of people in the west keep
saying there's you know right-wing
stupid ways of looking at it and
leftwing stupid but but one of them is
oh yeah Putin's a communist and he's
trying to rebuild the USSR which is just
so stupid like he keeps basically
criticizing Soviet leaders and Russian
leaders he keeps criticizing Lenin he
keeps criticizing Stalin he keep
criticizing
kushev and what he's basically basically
saying is it's my duty to undo the
mistakes of the past leaders
particularly the Soviet leaders and so
he's not trying to rebuild the the the
Soviet Union at all he's trying to
rebuild is the Russian Empire he's
trying to recapitulate within the
Russian State the Russian lands that are
historically Russian populated by
Russian people absolutely and it was
very very clear when when he spoke about
it and if you took the time to actually
listen you'll understand but there was
one point that we both found very
interesting and we've got the clip
coming up here which is him talking
about Poland and in 1939 before you play
it OT this is actually the entire point
of the historical monologue and this is
like the the quintessential bit that
tells you what he's actually saying I
really recommend people pay attention to
this so here it
is in 1939 after Poland cooperated with
Hitler it did collaborate with Hitler
you know Hitler offered Poland peace and
a treaty of
friendship an alliance demanding in
return that Poland give back to Germany
the so-called dancing cdor which
connected the bulk of Germany with East
Prussia and
cunnings after World War I this
territory was transferred to Poland and
instead of Danzig a city of dun
emerged Hitler asked them to give it
amicably but they refused of course
still they collaborated with Hitler and
engaged
together in the partitioning of
Czechoslovakia may ask you you're making
the case that that Ukraine certainly
parts of Ukraine eastern Ukraine is in
effect Russia has been for hundreds of
years why wouldn't you just take it when
you became president 24 years ago you
have nuclear weapons they don't if it's
actually your land why did you wait so
long
should I'll tell you I'm coming to that
this briefing is coming to an end it
might be boring but so when we both
watched it I watched it and I went
there's something off about that and I
saw you have quite a visceral reaction
why was that well first of all notice
that in the entire interview he never
actually answers this point that Tucker
made which is actually a good inter
ction from Tucker number one but
basically if you listen to what he's
saying first of all I mean the history
of that period is quite complicated he
talks about how Poland cooperated with
the Germans in in the Czech thing a
little bit of Truth to that but what's
interesting is he doesn't mention that
the Soviet Union collaborated with
Germany to split Poland in 1939 and the
Soviet Union actually got the bigger
half of Poland in that process um but
but there's something even more
interesting in this entire thing than
that which he says
Poland was given an opportunity to
amicably give back to Germany the land
that it rightfully was
taken and he's basically setting up the
argument for his own territorial
recapture aspirations which is you know
we made lots of peaceful overtures to
about this being our land and we were
rebuffed and he's essentially saying
Poland started World War II by refusing
what it should have done which is give
the land back back to Germany yeah and
this is the core of his hisorical
argument is we are entitled to our
former land and that's why he's
presenting Poland as the essentially the
the party that started World War II when
in fact actually the Soviet Union helped
Germany to split Poland between uh the
Soviet Union and Nazi Germany under the
the secret protocol to the molotov
ribbon trop act which people know about
the Nazi Soviet Alliance which lasted
for two years during which time the
Soviet Union provided food grain uh oil
uh and other supplies to Germany
including diplomatic help as well so
this is the core of his historical
argument essentially countries are
allowed to retake their land and if the
other country which currently has it
refuses to give it we can come in and
take it but don't you find it quite
interesting is because that's clearly
not correct it's historically in correct
so he's
justifying the war and The Invasion with
a point that's historically incorrect I
don't know that it is historically
incorrect I mean uh you look this is the
point I've made people don't like
hearing this but it is true uh Hitler
had a stronger case for uh annexing the
Sudan land uh reoccupying Czechoslovakia
the anlos his claims to polish lands
were in these terms
on this basis I'm not saying I agree
with it but on the basis that a country
is entitled to recapture lands that are
populated by its former populations by
its ethnic speakers who are being
mistreated there I mean the German uh
the Treaty of Versa took massive German
populated lands and gave them to
countries that didn't exist on a map at
that point you know during the period
prior to the Treaty of Versa Poland
didn't exist as it is then or now the
Czechoslovakia didn't exist the these
lands were populated to some extent by
Germans in the sedan land particular who
were being Mal maltreated not least
because of what Germany did in World War
I so um it's not that it's historically
inaccurate so much it's that if we
operate on this basis we would never
stop having Wars uh you know and from an
American perspective for example I find
it strange that Americans could have go
along with this argument half of America
used to be Mexico you know Cal used to
be England you we can we can carry on
down this path forever in fact you know
the two world wars in Europe basically
over alas Len who owns this tiny B land
between Germany and France how long do
you want to keep the [__] going no
absolutely absolutely and it it just it
seems that the people agreeing with this
point are people who fundamentally don't
understand history and don't understand
conflict and don't understand conflict
over territory or don't want to because
we got to recognize you know you and I
on this show have been covering the fact
that uh there's a section of the extreme
left that has become fundamentally
anti-western and anti-American in
particular Y and a chunk of those people
are big fans of Putin and what he's
doing uh for that reason and so they
will believe anything that he says and
there are also people on the extreme
right I don't mean the far right but the
people who are the anti-establishment
right there's a section of that
group it's hard to call them
anti-American because they think they're
Patriots but they are so an the American
Elite that they see anyone who hates the
American Elite as much as they do as an
ally without realizing what we'll I'm
sure talk about later what Putin wants
for America which is Decline and and he
talks about it quite openly later on
let's let's yeah so we'll come to that
later on in the interview now Putin was
actually very interesting because this
is the longest time that this is the
only time I've ever seen him interviewed
and he struck a very consiliary note so
when he was talking about the PO Soviet
NATO expansion he was saying look all we
wanted was to be part of your club and
at every turn we were we were
rebuffed what were we meant to do now
how much of that is accurate and how
much of that is him spinning a yarn to
make Russia look like the victim well
the thing is nobody really knows because
he keeps alluding to these conversations
that he had with Western leaders and he
says this is what I said and Tucker says
well what did they say back and he says
well I can't reveal private
conversations you should talk to them he
talks about one instance in particular
where he said to Bill Clinton uh you
know what would happen if Russia applied
to join NATO and Clinton sort of says oh
that'd be interesting and then
apparently later having spoken to his
team Clinton says actually we couldn't
do that um and Tucker quite smartly says
to him well would Russia have joined and
Putin gives this very koi answer like
well we would have seen so none of us
knows whether his question was sincere
or whether the answer was sincere or
whether the conversation happened the
way that he recalls it um but also I
think there's a truth to what Putin says
which is I don't think NATO would have
welcomed Russia because Russia is too
big a country to absorb with too strong
a view of its own um
and just the entire rationale of NATO
would not have made sense in that sense
so uh perhaps that I'm that may well be
Russia's experience post but uh whether
that you know justifies everything
that's happened since is question yeah
but it's a quite a ingenious PR tactic
to not come out as a strong man which is
everybody Associates him with but to
come out and say look we we just wanted
to be part of the club but the thing is
this argument that the West was so
hostile to Russia that he makes and he
says you know the Cold War commentators
just needed to continue their grift
basically what was implying so they kept
banging uh you know talking down Russia
and saying it's a threat was that your
experience of the last 20 is no it
wasn't mine you know London has been
overrun by Russian money quite a lot of
illegitimate money being laed here uh
likewise America is infiltrated had been
infiltrated with Russian money you know
the this the Russia was not seen really
as a hostile force in this country
certainly in this country and in Europe
not in Germany not in other places in
fact there was a lot of business being
done so this idea that the West you know
has been attacking Russia or rejecting
Russia since the collapse of the Soviet
Union I don't think that's observably
true oh okay now a lot of some there's
some people people like John M shimer
have made this point who have said you
know Ukraine was meant to be neutral it
was meant to be a neutral Nation it was
meant to be a buffer in between Russia
and the west and then and this is to
quote Vladimir Putin it became a
satellite state yeah and he talks about
five rounds of NATO expansion and
actually I have to say on this this
issue I think he has a pretty good point
like this is an irritant for Russia for
sure and we've talked about this before
right I think when we first ever talked
about he said to me well would Putin
have invaded if NATO hadn't been
expanding and the truth is we don't know
right certainly a factor in all of this
and is absolutely an irritant to Russia
um but the difference is that I think
Putin sees that as a deliberate ploy to
corner and antagonize Russia whereas I
think NATO expansion is largely a
product of some very crude and basic
things like every time NATO expands that
means the Weaponry of that country that
it's just expanded to is is changed to
Nato standard which creates a lot of
money for Western companies or American
companies to be specific to come in
rearm the entire country so the American
defense contractors are very interested
in NATO expansion so it's not that
people want wanted to you know oppress
poor little Vladimir Putin it was more
various things now doesn't excuse you
know NATO expansion because promises
were made um but the other reason of
course is most of all of the countries
that have joined NATO were terrified of
Russia's renewed aggression which
they've experienced over centuries and
so they wanted to join so it's like they
wanted to join and there was a lot of
business interest in having them join um
and that's probably why that happened
but certainly it's an irritant to Russia
for sure absolutely and
whilst your explanation of it sounds
plausible there is a certain amount
again I'm not saying what Russia did was
correct but I'm saying NATO needs to
take some responsibility because you may
do something which you don't think is
antagonistic gesture but can be
perceived at that and that's partly your
responsibility isn't it agree especially
if you go against previous agreements
because then Russia will look at it and
go well how can we trust you we signed
we signed the document you've broken the
document therefore what a point in
having any agreement and by the way one
of the I think the big cultural
differences here is obviously Russia is
not a democracy uh and so Putin doesn't
understand that he's dealing with uh
societies where the leadership changes
regularly and that means the Strategic
priorities decisions you know uh
policies change over time and so he's
like well in 1997 they promised me this
well not 197 in his case you know 1999
2000 2003 they promised me this and then
six years later they did that right but
he's not taken into account was a
different president by that point from a
different political party for example
right so I think that's one of the big
miscommunications there is he's sort of
treating America the West as one thing
that speaks with the one voice like
Russia has spoken with one voice since
1999 since when he took over and that
discontinuity of leadership is been an
issue here too absolutely let's just
have a quick look at this clip because
we're going to discuss that now Elliot
it's a 20 14
clip so in 2008 the doors of NATO were
opened for Ukraine in 2014 there was a
coup they started persecuting those who
did not accept the coup and it was
indeed the coup they created the threat
to Crimea which we had to take under our
protection they launched a war in donbas
in 2014 with the use of aircraft and
artillery against
civilians this is when it all started it
there is a video of aircraft attacking
donet from above they launched a large
scale military operation then another
one when they failed they started to
prepare the next one all this against
the background of military development
of this territory and opening of NATO's
doors how could we not express concern
over what was happening from our side
this would have been a culpable
negligence that's what it would have
been it's just that he uses the word
coup and that's a pretty strong word and
he also says you know that this was
backed by the CIA etc etc etc what do
you make of that is that a fair
representation of events so this is the
point where I think the paranoia partly
caused by NATO expansion is starting to
play its part
because I can see why he would see it in
this way however it really isn't what
happened so in the clip we played we
don't include the bit where he talked
about the trade agreement and this is
the really important part so he talked
about the fact that basically uh Ukraine
was about to sign a trade agreement with
the EU and then the president yanukovich
who was basically a pro-russian you
might say a Russian puppet whichever way
you look at it he was pro- Russian um
essentially Putin's argument is
yanukovich real realized that if he did
a free trade deal with the EU that would
mean Ukraine's free trade deal with uh
Russia would no longer be in place that
would be economically not what Ukraine
should do and so yanukovich went back on
this deal which is why those evil
westerners organized a coup this is
completely not what happened what
actually happened was yanukovich
promised to sign the CR trade agreement
and then he went back on it now the
reason for that may or may not be
perfectly legitimate it might have been
pressure from Russia it might have been
that he thought it was not a good deal
for Ukraine none of us know right
however what happened is a few students
in Kiev went out on the street to
protest against this because they were
pro-western and they wanted Ukraine to
move in a pro-western direction
representing about half of Ukrainian
Society but a small group of students
you know protest happened right they
were brutally beaten by the police and
when pictures and videos of this event
went basically viral in Ukraine people
then came out on the streets to protest
against what they saw is a tyrannical
government brutalizing its citizens and
that is when the street protest started
uh in Ukraine right so the maidan re
what ended up being the maidan
Revolution was started because of that
rejection of the of the deal and then
the police treatment of the protesters
right um and the police continually kept
aggravating the situation to the point
where eventually over a 100 people were
shot and killed by yanukovich we don't
know exactly which forces it was in
those Street protests that continued for
a long time and yes eventually that led
to the overthrow of the yanukovich
government that is what happened so is
that a CIA backed coup now I think it's
probably true that the West saw this as
an opportunity to help Ukraine move in a
western Direction and and this is by the
way true of all revolutions I mean if
you look at the American Revolution
something of which mer many people who
are very critical of this are very proud
of American Revolution was basically
funded by the French yeah to the point
where the French Revolution happened
because the French state was so bankrupt
after funding the American
Revolution that they didn't have any
money and the whole country went TI up
yeah so every revolution in history has
always been supported by the enemies of
the superpower that was in the do you
know what I mean yeah of course that's
the Venezuelan Revolution was exactly
the same funded by the British every
Revolution is like this right so but
what I'm saying is the Catalyst for this
was not the CIA the Catalyst for this
was the brutal treatment of the
protesters which then spiraled into
Street protest which then got more
brutal treatment which EV Del ended in
this now what's interesting is two
occasions in this interview continuing
from here Putin talks about well in 2014
this happened and then there was a
threat to Crimea MH never says what what
was the threat exactly Crimea was
Ukrainian territory what was the threat
to Crimea never explained this and it's
aity that Tucker never challenged him
because I would really like to have
heard this um now what what he actually
means I suspect don't know I don't know
what means I wish someone had asked him
but the sople Naval Base MH has been a
massive issue for Russia Ukraine
relationship since 1991 because it's
basically the the port in the Black Sea
from which Russia is able to project its
power into the Mediterranean mhm and the
debate about you know who should belong
to who should be controlling it whose
soldiers should be and sailors should be
stationed there had been ongoing since
1991 but basically Russia is paranoid
about that becoming a unavailable to
Russia and certainly B falling into
American hands so I guess what he means
is there was a threat that Ukraine would
become Pro Western and therefore we
would lose access to sopal so we had to
take Crimea but he never elaborates that
which is very very telling and also as
well he alludes to the fact that the
Ukraine Ian elections they weren't they
weren't honest they there was something
fundamentally dodgy well he talks about
the coup I think that's what he yeah the
coup but also he talked about zelinsky's
being elected and how that wasn't
particularly fair either he talk no no
he talked about yanovich and Yin taking
over from him so his argument basically
is you know uh I had my guys in Ukraine
uh and they were not getting reelected
through various means it was all the CIA
yeah that's his argument yeah so sounds
like a Latino right so we've got and
then moving on he starts talking and
this is
where he starts to get even more
conspiratorial which is the whole
densification thing he uses that word
densification and he goes into the
historical element of it how accurate is
a historical again his historical
telling of what happened in history is
accurate so uh what he's saying is
absolutely true during during uh World
War II there was a section of Ukraine I
mean we can call them Ukrainian
nationalists and we probably should
because that's accurate they were
actually not part of Russia or the
Soviet Union at the time they were
mostly living in what
was polish territory if you like um who
uh were basically fascists yeah you got
to remember they were not Nazis they
were fascist there is a difference
people these days don't understand the
difference you got to remember quite a
lot of Europe was fascist at this time
yeah absolutely Spain was fascist
Portugal was fascist there was
significant fascist movement obviously
in Italy significant fascist movement in
Central Europe and southern Europe um
there's quite a lot of them about I mean
one my my favorite historical factoid is
the people who defended the Reich stag
was a unit of the SS called SS
Charlamagne made up completely of French
fascists defending the right tag in the
last days of of of the Nazi war effort
um my point is a lot of Europe was
fascist at the time time and these
people uh were nationalists in that they
wanted Independence actually originally
from Poland yeah um and they saw
Hitler's Invasion as an opportunity to
free themselves both from Poland and
from the threat of Soviet occupation
okay and these people were horrible
people and they and Putin is absolutely
right they killed Russians they killed
the Poes and they killed the Jews and
they hated all of those people and Putin
is also right that in the attempt to
build a Ukrainian identity a lot of
mistakes were made including promoting
some of these people mainly because to a
large extent because of historical
ignorance they're sort of seen as the
the only people who fought for the
independence of Ukraine so their crimes
are kind of yeah ignored that's not the
same as saying Ukraine is now prazi or
anything like that because nobody in
Ukraine is no sorry not nobody every
country has a small Nazi contingent
Russia by the way uh I mean Dimitri
razin I always make this point who was a
deputy prime minister of Russia and
headed Russia's equivalent of NASA until
uh recently if not still uh he's on
camera openly giv the Nazi salute and
saying Russia for Russians and all this
other stuff so there's a Nazi problem in
all of Eastern Europe but my point is
Ukrainian Society is not overrun by
Nazis and Tucker actually very
effectively challenges him on this and
he says look whatever you say about
these people you know you're talking
about Ukrainian nationalism how do you
deal with that and again Putin doesn't
address it uh where what I thought was
more interesting in terms of this kind
of world view is Putin says we didn't
start the war in
2022 the war started in 2014 when they
attacked Ukraine attacked the Eastern
regions we saw it in the clip that we
just played and this is just nonsense
factual nonsense uh it's like saying you
know in um in the early '90s when I
still lived in Russia uh Chia tried to
break away from Russia mhm so what did
Russia do Russia attempted to prevent
that from happening by force this is
what countries tend to do when a region
basically a bunch of armed men say this
is no longer part of this country right
it's quite normal thing to do uh and
that's basically what happened in the
Eastern regions when this uh Revolution
happened in 2014 there were some people
in the Eastern regions who basically
started an AR armed Uprising backed by
Russia um uh who wanted to break away
from Ukraine and Ukraine attempted to
suppress this Rebellion which is quite
common in in history really so it's not
that Ukraine started a war it's that it
attempted to do exactly what Vladimir
Putin tried to do and eventually
succeeded in doing in Cheta which is to
prevent an armed rebellion and a
breakaway Republic from breaking away um
and to say that then in
2022 he continued defending Russia by
reinvading Ukraine after you know it's
just complete nonsense that's a bit
where he's just not telling the truth so
and it's very interesting that because
it is complete nonsense which makes me
think why is it why do you think he's
saying that why because well he he's
given it away at the beginning of the
interview this what I'm saying he sees
this as Russian
land and when Russian people rise up to
rejoin Russia yeah it's his duty as the
patriarch of all Russia to protect his
fellow countrymen and he keeps saying
this these are our people they speak our
language we got to protect them yeah
it's just very interesting because a lot
of the time I'm listening to him and I
go well I may not I may I don't know the
background of what he's saying but it
sounds plausible there are other things
that he's saying where I go I don't
agree but I can understand why you're
saying that and then there's other bits
like in that bit where I go well this is
just completely disingenuous and I would
have expected him to have been a lot
more skillful when talking about that
instead of give him what was actually an
outright light well that is how he sees
it I I genuinely think he believes it I
mean I think that is how he sees it and
I think we've talked about the paranoia
of the CIA and all of this stuff may
have some basis by the way you know big
powerful countries try to influence each
other you know they do all that um you
know is influencing how he sees
everything and so when a bunch of
Russian opposition activists start
something in Russia he can't imagine
that anybody would oppose his rule mhm
and he sees that as a CIA asset like you
know I've we've gone to Extinction
Rebellion protests in this country or uh
anti-british protest or Pro Palestine
protest but never occurs to me that
they're being funded by the CIA or mosad
or uh you know the KGB or whatever right
but in his mind any opposition to he
more to his country's interests or
whatever is funded by the CA and that is
how he sees the world not least because
he used to be an intelligence Secret
Service operative himself and so to him
of course everything is happening
because the CIA is doing it because he
knows that's how he operates and how his
country operates yeah so what it does in
a sense is engender a quite paranoid way
of looking at the world and he's been in
power for 25 years which as we know is
not exactly conducive to a kind of
open-minded and yeah and anybody who
gives him bad news I can't imagine he
takes it particularly well or challeng a
Viewpoint well a lot of people have said
and I think there's some credibility to
this is one of the reasons that he
actually did invade Ukraine in
2022 was that he thought it was going to
be a walk in the park MH uh if you look
at what they had tried to do
militarily uh it didn't look like
someone
seriously who thought they were in a
serious conflict they was they went in
with far too few troops they were not
well prepared they and they took very
heavy casualties because I think what he
was told is you know the Ukrainian
people will rise up and welcome you
because they're not Ukrainian they're
Russian and he just told you that
there's no such thing as Ukrainian
people they don't have a national
identity they see themselves as Russia
and they they they welcome back and in
fact the very end of the interview tells
us incredible story about how apparently
these Russian soldiers uh encircled some
Ukrainian soldiers and said surrender
lay down your arms and apparently those
Ukrainian soldiers said Russians don't
surrender and we're all killed
right so in his mind there are no
ukrainians yeah there are like
brainwashed Nazis and then there's the
majority of them who are Russians who
just desperate to rejoin the motherland
that's how he sees it which is very
interesting that he could have got
somebody so powerful could have got it
so wrong but then if you obliterate
anybody who disagrees with you that's
you're going to get you're going to get
an echo chamber and we've got an
interview coming out with historian and
I think you know well-informed guy
called Mark gallotti who makes this very
point absolutely now he is at pains to
say continually that he wanted peace
talks he wanted peace talks he even
blamed Boris Johnson for scuppering
them it's very interesting because again
presenting himself not as a strong man
but as this consiliary figure who's been
put in this position where he has no
choice but to behave in this manner well
I I agree mostly what you're saying I
would just maybe quibble a little bit
with your analysis I don't think he's
presenting himself not as a strong man I
think what he's presenting himself as a
strong man who's reasonable yes right so
he's like we invaded and we got some
progress and then we were willing to
negotiate and then Boris Johnson CED the
deal now in particularly in these kind
of uh anti-establishment left and right
circles this is a very popular
conversation you know Boris Johnson
prevented peace naftal Bennett the
Israeli Prime Minister had a deal
ready um it's actually ell are you about
to pull up the article that I sent you
um naal Bennett the prime minister of
Israel who's basically uh he was
allegedly was you know the deal was
ready and it was all good basically came
out and said this is not true the deal
was really scuppered by the fact that
when Russian soldiers pulled out of the
area they occupied near Kiev uh a lot of
Russian atrocities including Bucher were
found and from that point on there was
just you know the Ukrainian Society was
not going to do a deal and that's
basically what happened in terms of
Boris Johnson none of us know the
details of that deal because it hasn't
been revealed but my understanding is
basically they wanted significant
territorial concessions and all kinds of
other concessions and Boris Johnson was
saying no you know we'll help you fight
and and win back your land has that
proven to be the right decision in the
long run probably not at this point
because Ukraine given the dwindling
support in the West for continuing to
support Ukraine at the level it would
have needed to actually be able to do
that um
it hasn't turned out to be a good
decision I think uh but at the time you
know you don't know what the future is
going to be so I think Johnson's
argument was we'll we're on your side
we'll help you win the war or you know
win back your land or whatever it is um
which is not an unreasonable thing to
say to somebody who's about to basically
surrender yeah and he also addresses
this idea that Russia was going to take
Ukraine and it was going to continue
expanding and he said look I'm not going
to that why would I do that when
actually that is going to bring us to
the brink of global war I'm not crazy
I'll remind you that in 2014 he said
Russian soldiers are not in Crimea and
then gave out medals to Russian soldiers
who were in Crimea for taking Crimea
right not everything Vladimir Putin says
is always true right now you also got to
remember right we've talked about this
in the past and I've said he absolutely
has territorial Ambitions Beyond Ukraine
mhm and he does in my opinion I'll
explain to you why however does that
mean that now after what happened in
Ukraine he's going to invade Poland no
right because one of the things that
we've noticed is he's clearly didn't
expect the result that he got in Ukraine
even though I would argue that he's
winning yeah right um but the cost is
very high to him and to Russia Etc um
but if you play the argument that he's
making right at the beginning of the
interview for 30 minutes there's a
reason he spends that much time he said
he was going to take 30 seconds takes 30
minutes his argument is these are our
lands populated by Russian
speakers is Ukraine the only country
populated with some Russian speakers
what about laa what about
Lithuania what about Estonia there's
Russian minorities there by the way if
you want to make the argument that
they're oppressed absolutely you know
the Russian language is not permitted as
the second state language all sorts of
things going on so there's plenty that
he could do if he was if he found what
happened in Ukraine easy if Ukraine
crumbled in 3 days there's no reason why
he wouldn't like look NATO is obviously
a strong disincentive but my point is
you know to say now that he's going to
be like rushing into Poland is crazy
he's not yeah you know even though I
think he's going to get a form of win in
Ukraine and therefore be
disincentivized he has an expansionist
view of Russia because what he's trying
to do is recapitulate the Russian
right and because he was coming his
argument was that he didn't want to
endanger the world when that's something
that I don't think you particularly care
about when you invade another country
illegally because that is already a
destabilizing right event right and so
if he saw Russian speakers be oppressed
in lva you know would he start a
conversation about that would he see if
if NATO had entirely did nothing about
Ukraine would he see well maybe NATO is
not not going to do anything with that
do you know what I mean yeah so I think
the the the challenge to his invasion of
Ukraine was very important not least
because it has deterred further
aggression yeah and he was speaking
about the multi-polar world and the
world that we are now moving into and at
one point it sounded like a trigonometry
guest and I was it was it was very
interesting to hear him analyze it in
this way but he was talking about the
multi-polar world and he compared the US
to the Roman Empire in this clip and
it's a very interesting clip actually
Elliot if you can play it and we'll
dissect it afterwards I don't think
so my opinion is that the development of
the world Community is in accordance
with the inherent laws and those laws
are what they
are it's always been this way in the
history of mankind some Nations and
countries Rose became stronger and more
numerous and then left the international
stage losing the stat as they had the
custom
to there's probably no need for me to
give examples but we could start with
the king is Han and horde conquerors the
golden horde and then end with the Roman
Empire it seems that there has never
been anything like the Roman Empire in
the history of
mankind nevertheless the potential of
The Barbarians gradually grew as did
their
population in general The Barbarians
getting stronger and began to develop
economically as we would say
today this eventually led to the
collapse of the Roman Empire and the
regime imposed by the
Romans however it took five centuries
for the Roman Empire to fall
apart the difference with what is
happening
now is that all the processes of change
are happening at the much faster pays
than in Roman
times so when and it was very
interesting because he said those words
and he had a dare I say a smug little
smile on his face when he said it well
this is the one thing that a lot of
these I I look I don't like antagonizing
people but it does irritate me when
people don't understand what's going on
because they don't listen and they only
listen to The Things They want to hear
yeah right for example the na Bennett
thing that I brought up like you can
Google it in three seconds that na
Bennett has basically denounced the
thing that are being said about what he
said but nobody does right and the same
with Putin's speeches he's been saying
since day one American dominance is over
the time for the multi multipolar world
is coming and but what he means by it is
what he's just explained to you and I I
wish people would just get it what he's
saying is very simple there are natural
laws of History which is population and
economy is
Destiny China India Russia bricks as a
whole we are
the new force on the Block MH America
Europe and the West is in Decline and
either you accept this and go gently
quietly into the night or it's going to
be a painful process like the one you're
experiencing now right he's saying your
time is up you're not going to be the
world leaders anymore it's over that is
literally what he's saying over and over
and over and people are like you're a
wonger I'm like what he's saying and he
just told you again watch the interview
he he says this over and over and every
time the idea of the multi-polar world
comes up that is exactly what he's
saying he's saying the American Elites
are Clinging On to the power of the
American dominance they're using the
American dollar they're using this
they're using that to try and dominate
their the world your time is up it's
over right and he and he keeps referring
to this conspiracy theory that is very
popular in Russia and then also in parts
of the third world which is the golden
billion idea yeah and so he mentioned
the golden billion and I I was I mean it
sounds like a rapper what is the golden
B that is a great name for a rapper yeah
it's a brilliant name look the golden
billion is an idea that's been popular
in Russia since like even in you know my
childhood Even Cold War times and it's
basically the idea that what the
Americans really want uh the Americans
and the West in particular is for there
to be an elite group of people the top
billion people in the world who are rich
and comfortable and for everybody else
to be essentially enslaved to them uh
for them to profit off and to live in
poverty for the rest of Eternity right
so the golden billion they're going to
be rich and prosperous and comfortable
and everybody else is going to live in
mud shacks and that's what apparently
the Americans want and and this is
universal and he believes in he keeps
repeating it and so do lots of people
which is interesting given the evidence
not only the evidence but what he
himself is saying about how actually
China India you know Latin America
countries are doing Brazil obviously are
doing incredibly well
Indonesia um the world's population has
been lifted out of poverty at at a scale
that is completely unprecedented in
recent decades for one reason and one
reason in particular which is free
market the spread of free market
capitalism around the world that's why
people are getting wealthier in those
parts of the world so the idea that
westerners want to oppress everybody
else at their expense so that we can be
rich it's just factually and obviously
unobservably incorrect but when we talk
about a paranoid conspiratorial
worldview if you think about it there's
nothing more paranid paranoid and
conspiratorial than believing that other
people want to keep you poor yeah even
though you can see the main thing look
I'm not saying America doesn't want to
be the richest country in the world and
I'm not saying American corporations
don't want to exploit the the wealth and
the res resources of other countries but
other countries also want to exploit the
wealth and resources of America and of
other countries too this is the global
economic game right um but what has
happened with global trade it has been
disruptive for all societies but it has
also been massively beneficial uh to
those societies around the world which
is why everybody is so much richer so
much wealthier and so much more
comfortable so this is just like a
complete conspiracy that he and a lot of
people in that part of the world belief
and you know what's really interesting
as well is there was a disingenuousness
about it when he was talking about their
alliance with China when from the people
that we've spoken to including mark
gallotti saying the Chinese you know
it's they're not that friendly with the
Russians look the
Chinese they're they're very sensible
and they have a very long view of
History uh but I can tell you Russia is
absolutely terrified of China abs
terrified most of the Far East of Russia
is increasingly being effectively taken
over by by Chinese people who are moving
in on mass taking over local businesses
whatever H and uh as Putin himself
acknowledges China is a huge country
very very powerful and he says we've
been living peacefully together with a
massive border
for peacefully is a very dubious
statement given some of the things that
happened around World War II and and and
prior to that so um you know it's uh
it's a complete misnomer like it's not
an easy Alliance Putin has been pushed
into it by events uh but I he would much
rather be in Alliance with the West oh
yeah I I completely agree I think he'd
much rather be in Alliance with the West
than China and let's talk just a little
bit about sanctions the sanctions that
have been imposed on Russia what effect
is that having on the life of the
average Russian and the Russian economy
well he made this point actually that
despite the sanction Russia was the
biggest econom economy in Europe last
year yeah and it speaks to something you
know I've always been extremely
skeptical about the way sanctions have
been applied I mean the idea that you
were going to you know degrade Russia's
economy with Western sanctions was never
true um
and what we should have been doing is
very specifically targeting the supplies
of military equipment uh which by the
way there would have been way more
support for around the world people in
India really I mean you know the people
who run India and probably most of the
population in India people in Africa
people in China they don't really care
that much about the war in Ukraine they
were never on board with you know
slowing down the global economy to like
punish Russia they didn't see that way
at all um but they might have well have
been on board with sanctions you know to
prevent missile def missile systems
being developed or being built or being
you know cruise missiles being produced
and the west and Western technology was
used in a lot of Russian military
equipment so rather than focusing on on
the economic sanctions which have hurt
everyone but really Haven
disproportionately hurt Russia which is
kind of what you'd want to do if you
were applying sanctions in a smart way
uh just was not a good idea and you know
the West went overboard in a lot of
stuff you know like Banning Russian
performers from ballet and stuff he just
what are you doing no absolutely I mean
there was ridiculous you know instances
where people ban dead Russian composers
yeah I I was picking up someone up at
the airport like three months ago and a
guy came up to me who just recognized me
and was like look can you help me out
I'm Russian I a Russian passport and
they won't let me exchange money like
how does a normal person from Russia not
being able to change money in an airport
in England stop Putin's invasion of
Ukraine is so there was a lot of this
moral virtue signaling which the vest
the West is now infected with that got
concocted into strategy and suddenly we
were doing all this stupid stuff just so
that we could feel good about ourselves
instead of being more strategic and
practical yeah before we move on to your
questions so if you want to submit a
question for Constantin send a Super
Chat and we'll I'll put them to him
after the break do you think on
reflection the 2 hours 20 minutes what
do you think that Putin hoped to get out
of it and number two how do you think he
came
across um well this is something
interesting
because on your second Point how he came
across I think to most people in the
west he actually came across incredibly
well mhm not least because of the contra
with our leaders yeah and part of that
to put it gently is that some of our
leaders are not up to scratch mhm some
of them have dementia not mentioning any
names uh some and some of them just not
very capable MH but also you have to
recognize another thing which is
something that you know as our you and I
we do the show our profile increasingly
grows we meet politicians from different
parties and we talk to them you know in
the backgrounds of TV shows and all that
sort of thing and and elsewhere actually
most politicians many sorry some
politicians in the west actually quite
impress of people who could also hold
Court about the history of the UK or the
history of America for half an hour if
they had the opportunity to be
interviewed in the style that Vladimir
Putin was interviewed about and if they
had the opportunity to be in power for
25 years right it's not Vladimir Putin
didn't give interviews like this in 2001
he was not educated about Russian
history he couldn't talk about it in any
authoritative way um where a lot of
Western politicians could but they're
not facing the same media regime they're
constantly interrupted they're
challenged they're misrepresented
endlessly I mean look at you know an
obvious example how how much would
Donald Trump lied about misrepresented
endlessly by his own journalist Vladimir
Putin doesn't have to deal with that
yeah never has uh he got rid of the
Independent Media very quickly and you
know whatever you think about the Tucker
Carlson interview it was actually quite
in the style of trigonom interview where
you let people talk and you push back
every now and again um you it was not a
confrontational hostile interview so he
comes across very well uh and by the way
people will say I'm you know I don't
like Putin and I don't but it's not
because I don't think he's intelligent
or capable or smart strategically he is
all those things right so he comes
across well people are not used to
hearing from him they've been painted a
picture that he's some e you know he's
that guy Austin Powers Dr Evil Dr Evil
good name for for that character you
know he's sitting there stroking some
weird cat and he's not he's he's a
leader of a country who has a strategic
vision for his country he's I don't
agree with with a lot of what he says or
certainly with a lot of what he's done
but but that caricature is what he's up
against and it's very easy to look good
against that when you're given two hours
to kind of lay out your argument right
so I think he's come come across well um
and what was your first question uh why
do you think he's done that why do you
think he's agreed to this interview so
but this is one of the things I didn't
like about what Tucker did is Tucker
tried to pretend that he's the only
journalist that's basically tried to get
an interview with Putin he said I'm the
only journalist that's bothered to
interview and Putin's spokesman came out
and said this isn't true we've been
approached by Western journalists all
the time uh and serve a lot of Western
journalists now those people haven't got
those interviews and I I think that
tells you a story first of all uh he
knows who Tucker's audience are Tucker
has been cultivating this audience for a
long time I can tell you someone who's
been on the show many times well a
couple of times rather sorry I can tell
you someone who's been on the show a
couple of times that when I suggested to
his producer that we should talk about
this issue on which I disagree with
Tucker they refused to do it and I got a
when it came to talking about the stuff
that I normally talk about which is you
know work culture which we're equally
concerned about and whatever very happy
to to hear my thoughts when he came to
this very hostile immediately really uh
and really didn't want to hear it so it
wasn't like we disagree let's have a
conversation it's like no we're not
talking about this um so he knows who
Tucker's audience are Tucker's audience
are that section of the left and that
section of the right that we've talked
about before who for their own reasons
are uh either anti-American and
principal like former guest on the show
um Aron mat who said America's the
the Death Star the Death Star right or
the sections of the right who are so
anti- the establishment that they will
side with anyone who is anti- their
establishment including enemies of
America like Vladimir Putin so he knew
he was talking to a friendly audience
who would lap it up and if you open your
Twitter and look at all the right
leaning and left leaning accounts from
those sections they all lapped it up and
they all spread it to their massive
audience so do you think Putin saw it as
basically a very powerful PR exercise of
course what else is in it for him you
think he like it's not like he's a
podcast guest he's not not on the
podcast circuit is it maybe should be
Mak get a lot of views clearly but you
know he's got a country to run so he's
not running around doing podcasts to him
this was an opportunity to speak to the
people in the west who already agree
with him and he spoke to them
Constantine thank you very much if you
want to ask Constantine uh a question
please send us a Super Chat and then
we'll put your questions to Constantin
after the break thanks for watching
we'll be back in a couple of
minutes I mean I think what we might be
missing is there is a tendency to think
of him is this kind of bond villain I
think what we have to realize is the
degree to which he's also a scared and
rather limited old man when even the
boss doesn't want to know what's really
happening that's when you you are on a
path to potential disaster and this
invasion of Ukraine was a classic
example he doesn't think that it's
ukrainians wanting to join the EU and
NATO he thinks it's the EU and NATO
wanting to steal Ukraine it's just the
minor point being it's all
nonsense C in please OT
yeah to the boys uh so this is from CLA
this is the first question this is from
our locals our local get first dibs
because these are the people that
Francis come on yes sell locals yes of
course sorry sorry it's my left wi
nature yes so we're giving first dibs to
the people from our locals they're
basically our patreon we're going to
give them first dibs to ask consenting
questions because they're the ones who
support us financially so Claire says do
the boys think Tucker's interview is
going to have any bearing on the
direction of the war I.E will political
leaders have to modify their plans in
order to Plate the public well one of
the things that Tu uh Putin did quite
effectively there is he kept presenting
himself as this reasonable guy who's
willing to negotiate now you can tell
what he's really really saying is I'm in
a position of strength Tucker keeps
saying to why don't you call the
American president and settle this and
he's saying why would I call anyone they
should call me right he's basically
saying I've got you by the balls uh and
it's time if you want to negotiate I'm
willing to hear it um and so I think
that's another one of the reasons that
he did this interview he's trying to
present himself to the Western public in
particular you know there's no need for
a warn Ukraine just come to the table
and let's settle this yeah it's very
yeah like I said it was very interesting
the way he chose to represent himself in
a way that actually took me by surprise
should we do more locals yeah we'll do
more locals uh so um Jenny says uh thank
you Jenny what is your opinion of Tucker
now look Tucker is what Tucker is I
don't I agree with him on a lot of
things I disagree with him on some
things including this has my opinion of
him changed based on this not
particularly fair so MRI asked was Putin
really describing the West obsession
with woke Etc in a derogatory manner
what are the chances he and others are
behind that prop propaganda in the first
place um I don't think he talked about
that much on this interview he keeps
talking about JK Rowling and trans and
whatever because he knows again that the
Tucker audience will will be interested
in that yeah um but yeah look he he's a
leader of a of AA country with
Traditional Values that's not protrans
yeah Believe It or Not uh and sees a lot
of what's happening in the west as
decadence which by the way so do I yes
um and so it's not like he's going to be
a fan of that but I do think he's
talking about it because it appeals to
the people who he thinks are listening
interesting uh can we scroll down please
Elliot so we can get more of our locals
okay uh this is very interesting this is
from polysaturated and they ask who has
a more believable story about the
destruction of the nordstream
pipeline I I never bought the idea that
Putin destroyed the nordstream P
pipeline I thought that was idiotic um I
look I have no idea who destroyed it but
if I had to guess I'd say it was the
Americans yeah and I think that was
pretty fair and I that was what he
saidas pretty much yeah exactly did he
did he mention the CIA again he loves a
bit of the CIA well like on some issues
he's got a point yeah right in this
instance in particular I don't think
Russia would blow up their own pipeline
that they spent billions building yeah
so this is is quite a provocative
question yeah so but I'm going to put it
anyway and this is from misanthropic put
any provocative question you want uh do
you think part of the issue was that
Tucker was woefully unprepared for what
he was
facing I don't know how prepared he was
because you didn't ask that many
questions he may have been very well
prepared but we we don't know right but
in as an interviewer you have to pick
your spot yeah we know this people often
criticize us for not not asking enough
challenging questions or whatever you
got to pick your spots you can't
interrupt somebody every 3 seconds if
you want to let them explain what they
mean so should he have gone in and
started debating the history of
Russia maybe should he have gone in and
started saying well actually you know
your rendering of the Polish situation
in 1939 isn't you know you got to pick
your spots yeah so I I don't know why he
didn't Challenge on certain things that
I would have challenged on and maybe
because he didn't know or maybe because
he chose not to maybe because it's not
his priority maybe he sees himself as
someone who's this is one shot to bring
peace to the world and so he's he wants
to focus on the negotiation instead of
the historical argument I don't know if
he was underprepared I mean there's also
the other argument that he could say is
that he came in he exposed Putin we've
now seen the flaws in his thinking the
conspiratorial nature isn't that part
part of what an interview's role is an
interviewer's role is not just to
challenge not just to push back but to
expose the heart of the individual in
front of you you I don't know I'm going
to say I'm going to do a Putin line here
and you say you'd have to ask Tucker
yeah Tucker we know you're watching mate
come on the show uh s says is is Putin's
historical analysis which presumably
lays a foundation of his claim to
section of Ukraine going back to the 9th
century regardless of how much is
debatable sincerely held do you think
well I I I not only think it's sincere
held I do think it's accurate the
question is do we want to renegotiate
the borders of countries endlessly on
the basis of historical claims my view
we don't yeah and I completely agree
with you Arch duuk albino says I'd love
Constantine kiss this is a great
question actually gut reaction to
Putin's use of language he's phrasing
all Cadence in those moments when I
think we can all agree he was visibly
annoyed by Tucker's question or
interjection specifically whether he was
putting on a show whether it indicates
he was genuinely annoyed I didn't think
he looked annoyed at all to be honest he
was kind of his usual demeanor nothing
different really his huffing and puffing
is just part of his persona it's very
typical typically Russian kind of like
serious face and then someone go you
know U he didn't look annoyed to me at
all he didn't he didn't look in any way
fluster or he he didn't look under
pressure at all look when Tucker started
asking him about the journalist I think
he was starting to get irritated by the
same question being asked but but apart
from that I don't think so yeah Megan
McKenzie asks an absolute belter of a
question well done Megan thank you for
sending a Super Chat what would the one
question be that you would ask
Putin well we talked about one of them
you said there was a threat to Crimea
yeah what did you mean in
um and the obvious question is you know
what is the settlement that you would be
prepared to accept at this point
yeah and that is both good questions
maros says is it me or was Putin found
lacking he has he Tru so fallen so much
to be reduced to this rambling to
lecture for hours what was without
substance was this all he ever
was I don't agree with the idea that he
was rambling Western viewers are not L
not used to his the way he is yeah so
they when they see a politician talking
for two hours they about history they
automatically assume he's rambling
whereas he sees himself as this you know
polymath he's educating you about the
history of Russia and whatever uh so I
don't think he's rambling I just think
he he's used to having as I said right
at the beginning you know three hours to
lay out his case um very good so uh BJ
Allen asks from locals why now I why
haven't we had an interview like this
before for now so why at this particular
moment do you
think I honestly don't know I don't know
whether Fox News would let Tucker
interview uh Vladimir Putin uh I don't
think this interview was anything crazy
but you know I think it's fair to say
that since he's left Fox he's loosened
the the boundaries of the sort of people
that he interviews so maybe that's why
hasn't happened I don't I don't know
genuinely okay uh me so uh we've got a
few ones we've got one about aliens why
didn't Tucker ask Putin about aliens I
mean I don't think that would have been
uh because obviously Tucker is big into
that uh we'll have a look I bet Joe
would have asked him about ali oh yeah
yeah absolutely they would have got the
cigars out it would have been really
good it would have been a lot of fun
um so let's see if we've got uh there
was one about uh the coup that kept
coming up have you got that one yeah no
I haven't seen that now okay let's do
this is a good question elizah right now
says can Putin be considered a good
leader in terms of being Russia first as
parrow to America
first um well it depends on what look uh
Putin has overseen a period of
extraordinary growth for Russia is it
all he doing no mainly it's a product of
the fact that oil prices went up and
there was a huge economic burn he didn't
particularly take that uh money and
rebuild Russia into a powerful
manufacturing base or whatever it's just
basically a big petrol station a big oil
pump whatever you want to call it um
does he put the interest of his country
first yeah does he want to make it
strong yeah um have all the decisions
that he made been in Russia's best
interest no but then that's probably
true of a lot of leaders um do I think
his decision to invade Ukraine was a
long-term benefit to Russia I guess we
don't know yeah is the truth
genuinely we genuinely don't know I mean
you know hundreds of thousands of
Russian people have died and ukrainians
have died and it's caused all sorts of
trouble in the world whether that
benefits Russia in the long term we just
genuinely don't know no absolutely and
we no one does and we we'll see what
happens as we move as we move on finally
triggered on locals says and by the way
if you haven't joined locals you
absolutely should you get to ask our
guest questions you get extra content
you get to behind the scenes it's
fantastic the uh finally triggered says
at one point Putin seemed to make the
distinction between the Practical West
and C cerebral intellectual Russia
fascinating why does he think like this
oh all Russians think like this
basically what he was saying uh politely
is what most Russians think impolitely
which is Western as a shallow and
consumerist and Russians are deep and
meaningful people with you know real
kind of you know serious
and they don't care about material
possessions and that's why there's such
a strong patriotic spirit in Russia as
you said some truth to that by the way
yeah oh yeah absolutely but the fact the
idea that you know Russians aren't
consumerist having seen Russians on Bond
Street coming out of you know you
remember that is a parous sver of
Russian Society yeah absolutely like if
you go to Brighton on a Saturday night
that's not necessarily representative of
all people in Britain well it's My
People Mate um so uh Scott on local says
what is uh KK's response to the comment
about the impact of bricks and US
influence in World
politics I don't remember exactly what
he said on that other than that it's
growing and get I think we kind of
addressed it in the main interview okay
Glenn Schuman asked a historical
question uh by sending in a Super Chat
there was also no discussion the holid
theore not to justify this but could
this have been part of the motivation
for ukrainians becoming Nazi during
World War I of course it was of course
it was the reason that a lot of these
people thought Hitler was a liberator is
the experience they had from the Soviets
was Believe It or Not Francis worse than
what Ukraine experienced under Hitler
yeah so under German Nazi occupation
somewhere around 4.6 million people were
killed in Ukraine mhm WOW 7 million
people starved in a Hol only years prior
MH so if you've just seen your country
in their opinion deliberately starved to
the point where people were eating their
own
children yeah how are you going to feel
about the regime that caused that and so
the people who were now look I say again
some of the people who collaborated with
the Nazis were fascists they were
anti-semitic they hated Jews they were
happy to kill Jews and Poes and Russians
but a lot of the people they were stuck
between these two terrible dictators
murderous dictators and they thought
they didn't know about the Holocaust at
the time a lot of them because the
Holocaust hadn't happened
yet and so they just saw this as well
maybe these guys will be better than
these evil guys maybe these guys will be
3% better yeah at least we won't be
starving to death but I say again there
were also some fascists who were
murderous anti-semitic and evil yeah and
people use history as a way to justify
their own view world view and also their
own actions and you can that's the thing
about and it's not just the Hol or by
the way it's collectivization where
essentially all the had their property
taken away it's the purges in the 19 in
the N end of the 1930s is basically the
Soviets brutalized the entire country
for 20 years it's no surprise that quite
a lot of people at the end of that
didn't want to support that regime
didn't want to fight it's one of the
reasons the Soviet armies got so badly
decimated in the first year and a half
of the war because they didn't want to
fight for Stalin quite understandably so
and that's why Germans the the the
number of prisoners Germans took so many
prisoners they literally didn't have
enough German soldiers to Convoy them to
the camps yeah why are you going to
fight for someone who more than likely
has either imprisoned your family member
or killed one or made you starve or your
family starve yeah yeah yeah it's yeah
absolutely okay this is a provocative
one but has Selinsky failed Ukraine uh
huge deaths for the dream of NATO EU
membership when he could have CED the
Russians the Russian leaning ukrainians
and worked with Russia and the EU
I don't know the answer to that question
nobody does nobody knows what the
alternative would have been um I I don't
know that it was possible for him to do
that because he was elected on a strong
Pro Western position yeah
so if he hadn't pursued that he wouldn't
have been doing what he was elected to
do yeah um and also you know it lays the
blame for everything that happened
entirely on him which I don't think is
reasonable given that it's Vladimir
Putin who invaded and it's very easy for
people to sit in the comfort of their
own home yeah when somebody is a leader
of a Nation at War yeah I imagine that's
quite
stressful you know there's a bit of
pressure on on your shoulders yeah um
AOS mucho says uh who will Putin and we
talked about this with Mark gallotti and
but I I I'll put it to you because it's
a good question who will Putin choose as
his successor if the time has come how
come that no one has asked him this yet
well we asked a historian called Mark
Alot this very question and watch our
interview and find out yeah absolutely
it's a great interview as well Mark Mark
is a splendid man on locals Krill Taran
says does Putin use Tucker Carlson as a
useful idiot and what would you say to
someone who claims that what Tucker did
is real
journalism well we we open the whole
inter talking about this I think that's
really the real journalism point is Up
For
Debate
um Putin is definitely using Tucker does
doesn't mean Tucker isn't using Putin
they're using each other oh absolutely
which is what all interviews kind of are
in some way not this one mate this is
just love um stay away
from Paul says you mentioned earlier
about unilateral power China and Russia
coming uh China and Russia
coming uh rising in dominance and the
West declining what would that world
look like with a dominant Russia or
China I always say the same thing to
people look at Mexico look what happens
when you take out one cartel yeah what
happens it's not good and then another
cartel becomes a dominant cartel yeah or
what's possibly even worse is that
you've got multiple dominant cartels
well that comes first and then
eventually after brutal war after brutal
war after brutal War another dominant
cartel emerges yeah so the you know is
Chinese rule of the world going to be
better than American
I don't think so no not for us no I'm
not [__] learning Chinese mate no no
food's good though uh o Bender his name
I'm not saying those words although
someone will probably clip me uh can the
lads discuss likelihood of puting being
a pathological liar and him being able
to pass the polygraph test with flying
colors there is no such thing as an X
KGB operative well there's a famous line
from a KGB agent who was asked how do
you pass a lie detection test and he
said get a good night's sleep and tell
the truth and that's because if you're
the polygraph test is complete [__]
by the way you know this right yeah yeah
I remember it only measures your
nervousness level so if you're not
nervous when you're lying which it's
very easy to not be nervous if you're
lying if you've been trained to do this
like a KGB agent might be um or will be
then it's not very hard um I don't think
Putin is a pathological liar I think
Putin uh sees the truth as um a tool to
be used for his ends in other words how
do I use the truth to tell the story
that I want to tell and how do I not
tell the part of the story that I don't
want people to hear yeah and he's very
calm about that because in his mind the
rationale will be I'm doing this for the
greatness of
Russia yeah and he and he's lied over
and over by the way I gave the example
of him saying Russian troops annoying
Crimea then you know a month later oh
yeah it was Russian troops and and like
you can Google it there's there's hours
of evidence of him saying one thing that
he then contradicts or saying something
that then turns out completely false and
he knew it at the time yeah by the way
well a lot of Western leaders lie a lot
too I mean that's what politicians do
Putin is at the end of the day a
politician absolutely uh and a white man
so terrible man uh left leaning says is
he going to ncus
no yeah I think uh I I I really dislike
this idea that you know he's mad or
insane and he's got his finger hovering
over the button I think it actually is
demeans him well one of the things that
um he tried to say was like oh the
Western Elites are scaring their
populations by saying you know Russia is
threatening to use tactical nuclear
weapons it wasn't the Western Elites
that said that he was openly nuclear
doing open nuclear saber rattling during
this conflict from the beginning oh
really yeah yeah so we are prepared use
any means necessary and just kept saying
this over and over moved nuclear weapons
to bellarus uh left the treaty or
suspended Russia's participation in one
of the treaties so he's been nuclear
saber rattling himself but I don't think
there's absolutely there's no intention
of doing that no th those
are not least because he feels very
comfortable with where he is in Ukraine
now yeah and also as
well the moment you do that you open the
proverbial Pandora box and you do not
know what he's going to be Unleashed and
the chances are it's not going to end
well for you and he wants to live yeah
look how far away he used to sit during
Co from people well he knew about social
distancing before all of us mate yeah
anyway so uh so this is from George n
narad if I haven't pronounced it George
it's your fault not mine should have had
a simpler name uh he says KK you
mentioned at the beginning that Ukraine
is indeed an artificial country do you
think Ukrainian culture identity and
language are
artificial no they're not
artificial but Ukraine as a country is
made up of pieces of other countries and
was created quite recently that's a fact
yeah doesn't mean that I have family who
are Ukrainian doesn't mean I think their
language or the culture or whatever is
artificial uh but the country
territorially is but so are a lot of
countries yeah absolutely I mean I was
going to say Belgium but that is
definitely a fake country yeah it is
it's not prop serious country we're
joking there are a lot of countries that
are formed in this way doesn't mean that
other countries are entitled to invade
them no absolutely and you know the term
artificial is kind is quite loaded
because you go you know what country
isn't artificial in in many ways there
are some yeah there are some there are
some countries that are just pure nation
states have been always are have been
and will remain that way um but there
are some countries that are not yeah and
it doesn't mean that there are any more
valid or have any more any less right to
exist in other ones so we've got one
we've got a question from locals it's
paie Marsh is quite literally being
typed up now I can hear Jack's fingers
or Elliot's fingers moving furiously as
it's coming up on the screen uh he says
looking forward to your take KK as you
have firsthand experience of the culture
so thank you very much we've had load of
loads of supportive messages by the way
um to me Putin comes across as far more
pragmatic than most western leaders am I
getting sucked in um no what's happening
is you're
misreading Putin doesn't have to have
popular
support so he doesn't have to sell his
views to the public therefore he doesn't
have to Virtue signal therefore he can
say what he wants in a way that a normal
Western leader can't yeah he doesn't
have to Virtue signal that's what's
happening yeah and he doesn't have to
Panda and he doesn't because he's not
worried about opinion polls he's not
worried about getting reelected yeah
yeah he can just shoot from the hip yeah
in a way that our leaders can't um Gary
says uh what do you guys think if Boris
Boris Johnson literally intervening to
Pro to prolong a war that could have
been halted well we've already talked
about this we have talked about it so go
back early in the interview we discussed
all this uh so BJ Allen says why now we
have so we've we've already come across
that have we got any other questions
boys or is that pretty much it we've got
a couple more com about the super chats
is there no there's there was definitely
one I saw one about somebody trying to
challenge me which I wanted to pick up
on which was about uh we've got 50 Quid
from OG rods for example that I can see
uh can you see that one uh no I can't if
Hitler was similarly interviewed one
might have concluded legitimacy with
some of his positions but clearly evil
was able to manifest through that
Godless man the key question to Putin
was whether he recogn nice higher forces
at work he didn't um yeah I guess that's
not a question but thank you for that
aods um I'm sorry if we've missed a
bunch of super chats there is a lot
there are a lot of messages coming in so
we haven't been able to pick all of them
up for sure uh we've got a couple of
Paul Cherry says how do we stop the
decline of the West and stop the rise of
China and Russia well we've been talking
about this for quite a long time the
West needs to ReDiscover it
self-confidence and stop being
divided J chicken has a question I don't
know maybe I I don't uh maybe you'll be
able to answer it will there be advice
on extracting yourself from a deep coma
is
that no okay uh int boom says Putin uses
a land claim from the year 800 to
justify his invasion of Ukraine does
this mean that any progressives who
think this makes no sense should stop
using the history of slavery as a tactic
they should stop using the history of
slavery as a tactic because their
interpretation of the history of slavery
is moronic that's why they should stop
using
it so James burlo says here in America
so no it says the words you know and I
think this is you know let's put it uh
kindly it's a less mainstream narrative
James bero says no here in America
Washington DC has been hostiled and
determined to keep Russia crippled and
prevent Germany from becoming truly
independent that's probably a good
idea uh Eric by the way says please
don't use business inside as a credible
source which is why Elliot I put put in
a link to naftali Bennett's own Twitter
in which he dismisses the claims that
are being made about what he said can we
pull that up cuz I knew somebody would
say this
yeah so U mic says trigonometry please
check diesel baby Super Chat that's the
one with the challenge yeah that's the
one I was uh alluding to uh uh diesel
bab if you put it back in yeah I'll read
it out I'm sorry we've been able to miss
it I really wanted to get to it because
I wanted to talk about the stuff that
people wanted to challenge me on cuz
that's really important yeah okay uh so
guys we've got the Eugene uh he says how
do you feel about Putin you if you can
bring that up for me then I can uh I can
ask
Constantin ker says this feels like a
coded message we're ready to talk well
that's what he was saying we're in a
very strong position and we're ready to
talk uh okay so um Eugene can you just
clarify the last word please gentlemen
because it doesn't make sense thank you
so um how do you feel and this is from
Eugene G I think is how do you feel
about Putin using the phrase a job is a
job when referring to the cia's choice
of of Russia as an opponent and thus
supporting the Ukrainian Maiden coup
Maiden cou well what he's saying is I'm
a KGB Edge and I can't exactly slag off
the CIA for doing their job yeah uh
Justin says KK is so desperate to both
sides this interview it's almost like
you're trying to be nuanced mate or you
are nuan to tell the truth yeah yeah so
there we go I'm sorry we didn't Panda to
your particular predilections Justin we
will try better next time no we won't
yeah uh In Bloom says uh Putin uses a
land claim from the year 800 to just oh
we've done that one uh okay I think
that's pretty much it no we do have that
question that I I'm desperate to get to
from a guy who sent the Super Chat in
about four times I don't want to let go
of that and also Megan McKenzie has sent
one okay is it is is it why you claiming
my D was a bunch of students is this
okay we've got it diesel baby says why
are you claiming mid was a bunch of
students and ignoring downplaying role
of far right par paramilitary groups
like right sector tons of RS Flags In
Crowd during John McCain's speech it's
on video so you misinterpreted what I
said diesel uh what I said is the reason
Myan started was the students who were
protesting once they were beaten up tens
of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of people went out into the
street I have friends who were on the
streets of Kev during that period of
time who were not right-wing or far
right or anything of the kind they were
just decent Ukrainian people who
objected to the way those students were
treated and as in any protest you're
going to get some people who are uh you
know it's like this thing with Kelly J
Keen the guy turns up to her event and
he's he's some kind of Nazi or whatever
and suddenly everyone's a Nazi there was
an an element of the far right there
yeah um if there was a pro if there was
a revolution against the ri that
government I bet there' be some Far
Right protesters there too so uh you
know January of the 6th were there some
far right people there I'm pretty sure
they would have been yeah you know this
is kind of what happens absolutely Megan
says what do you think the results of
the Canadian government inviting a Nazi
into Parliament were for Putin zalinski
and the West well right this is one
thing we didn't talk about Putin kept
presenting this as like Ukraine is
zinski didn't know this guy was a former
Nati yeah neither did the people in the
Canadian Parliament it's just what
happened was uh as we talked about
before the West went into this moronic
virtue signaling phase they were just so
desperate to be anti-russian in
everywhere they did lots of stupid stuff
yeah and so yeah as and they weren't
thinking strategically etc etc In Bloom
says thank you Constantine it's
surprising to me how few otherwise smart
westerners understand how Russians think
you're the
best you thank you um yeah my voice is
going mate so a lot of people are now
commenting on my voice a lot of people
commenting on your voice sound sexy and
husky sexy and husky right Francis is
now attracted to me yeah exactly stay
tuned this will be on locals no so let's
wind up with this the difference between
the way Russians think and the way the
Brits think because I don't think people
understand this enough and I think it's
really helps to clarify Putin's
character and the way he's behaving
since we have like 10,000 people
watching live rather than giving you my
take I'll actually refer uh people to uh
a talk by a former guest of ours who is
the first guest of ours who's passed
away oh I Monty carry yeah bless
absolutely and uh he gave an incredible
talk it's in Finnish but there are
subtitles in it there's also a voiceover
version I um I wish I could remember the
exact title but it's something like
finish intelligence Colonel explains why
Russians think the way they think or
something like that uh and it's the best
explanation of how Russians think and
how it's different to the way people in
other parts of the world think that I
have ever heard literally like
99.99% of what he says in my opinion is
exactly true I really recommend people
check it out absolutely and Marty was
also on the show and gave a brilliant
interview as well and he also provided
some insight there yeah thank you so
much for watching thank you so much for
commenting thank you so much for sending
super chats thank you to everybody on
locals who is supporting us and put
forward your questions and we'll see you
very soon with another fabulous
interview take care and see you
soon I mean I think what we might be
missing is there is a tendency to think
of him as this kind of bond villain I
think what we have to realize is the
degree to which he's also a scared and
rather limited old man when even the
boss doesn't want to know what's really
happening that's when you you are on a
path to potential disaster and this
invasion of Ukraine was a classic
example he doesn't think that it's
ukrainians wanting to join the EU and
NATO he thinks it's the EU and NATO
wanting to steal Ukraine it's just the
minor point being it's all non